tu passes pour un mec qui sait tout et
il te manque une fiche sur Salvatore
particularité anatomique que tu sembles
ignorer
bonsoir bonsoir alors je suis très
content de vous accueillir parce que je
demande depuis 2 ans dans cette
interview psy est-ce que vous êtes
est-ce que vous êtes Adamo et c'est toi
les gens sont beaucoup Adamo moi j'ai
relancé dev je ne sais pas si je fais
en tout cas
est-ce que vous êtes Adamo et la
prochaine fois ce sera est-ce que vous
êtes Obispo et Obispo rentrera voilà
bien alors vous avez vendu 80 millions
d'albums en 35 ans c'est une moyenne
honorable c'est pas mal quand même c'est
pas mal c'est beaucoup non franchement
je croyais pas et au-delà de ces
chiffres la même personne bravo non mais
c'est fou non mais c'est vrai
puis ça va mieux là pour vous au niveau
de l'image ces temps-ci là ça va on
commence à dissiper un certain
malentendu par c'est vrai j'ai lu
d'ailleurs beaucoup de bons articles sur
vous dans des journaux comme comme
libération comme Télérama et c'était pas
il y a une quinzaine d'années et même
encore
5 ans c'était pas c'était pas le cas non
c'est vrai que on m'avait laissé dans le
tiroir des chanteurs des années 60 un
peu fleur bleue moi je l'image ne me
déplaît pas du tout mais disons que
c'était une facette de ma personnalité
on occultait trop l'autre où j'ai écrit
quelque chose plus concernées comment
ce nouvel album s'appelle par les temps
qui courent 16 nouveaux titres
écrits par vous paroles et musique il y
en a une qui a retenu mon attention
c'est le monde à mal que une chanson que
vous avez écrite
j'ai visité les camps de réfugiés à la
frontière du Kosovo
tant d'absurdité je pouvais pas
m'empêcher d'écrire cette chanson oui
vous étiez en Albanie à koukas c'est ça
ambassadeur de l'Unicef mais alors
aujourd'hui quand vous voyez
l'expansionnisme albanais en Macédoine
par exemple et cette volonté de faire la
grande Albanie est-ce que finalement
vous avez pas envie de faire une autre
chanson
vous savez ce n'est pas systématique il
faut que que je m'imprègne du problème
et puis il y a des choses qui qui
m'interpellent et d'autres moins quand
vous avez fait la chanson qui s'appelait
qui s'appelle inchallah sur Jérusalem
vous avez corriger vous avez fini par
corriger deux strophes parce que vous
aviez oublié de parler de la souffrance
de l'autre camp si vous n'avez pas peur
avec cette chanson qui se passe la même
chose c'est-à-dire que vous parlez que
d'un camp est-ce que finalement votre
boulot
rejeté pour chasser donc il y a pas de
nationalité précise alors la sortie de
cet album correspond au début de votre
tournée qui a commencé le 27 février à
l'Olympia votre salle fétiche vous avez
fait votre premier Olympia en 63 je vous
regarde parce que vous ici vous pouvez
vous souvenir de ça
vous êtes non 51
et alors non mais en 63 donc vous faites
l'Olympia avec Cliff Richard et les
Shadows vous vous souvenez de la page
quand même les Shadows
bien et puis après bon bah voilà la
tournée va continuer elle commence en
France Belgique Suisse Japon du Québec
etc d'ailleurs
tous les deux mois à peu près tous les
deux mois et lui vient
tous les combien
ça dépend quand je travaille quand il
travaille
cet été Adamo sort un roman vous avez
écrit qui sort chez Albin Michel qui
s'appelle et paisible coule la haine
alors on s'imagine qu'il s'agit de N et
en fait pas du tout la haine c'est une
rivière c'est la rivière qui traverse
Jemappes où j'ai vécu la première partie
de ma vie et je n'invente rien je
m'avais été au confluent de la haine et
de la trouille c'est incroyable c'est
comme ça
qui va être content
[Applaudissements]
bien en fait vous n'êtes pas du tout nu
à Jemappes mais vous êtes né en Sicile
en 1943 à Cosimo vous êtes né d'une
famille de 7 enfants votre père était
maçon il s'appelait Antonio c'est une
émission très papa maman j'ai décidé et
votre mère s'appelait concheta
absolument
et vous dites que votre timidité votre
mélancolie ça vient d'elle ça vient de
conchetta je pense oui même peut-être la
façon de chanter chanter souvent des
cantines sicilienne en cousant brodant
alors après la guerre que votre père a
passé dans l'aviation votre père revient
ici évidemment c'était chômage et
désolation et il y avait un comme ça une
rumeur qui disait dans le Nord il y a du
travail
dans le Nord et aussi en Amérique du Sud
et je me dis souvent que serais-je
devenu si mon père comme mon oncle le
matin avait choisi l'Amérique du Sud oui
l'Argentine et alors cette espèce de
phrase d'espoir comme ça circulé les
hommes parlaient de ça le soir ils
disent dans le Nord en Amérique du Sud
il y a du travail et votre père part et
que ça valise en carton
on peut réécrire
et donc quelques mois plus tard il
revient vous cherchez il a trouvé une
place dans une mine de charbon en
Belgique et en 47 vous prenez le train
pour la première fois vous avez quatre
ans et vous partez en Belgique voilà
travailleur immigré vous allez d'abord à
Ghlin dans une cité ouvrière c'est
l'ancien baraquement de prisonniers de
guerre c'était dur quand même des
petites baraques autour
pour moi tant que j'avais la main de mon
père d'un côté c'est de ma mère de
l'autre j'étais bien j'étais au soleil
mais pour eux qui étaient très jeunes le
déracinement a dû être très dur vous
écoutez quand même la radio italienne
c'est baraquement la vie et la vie est
dure mais quand même effectivement il y
a des bons moments de temps en temps vos
parents le dimanche qui dansent enlacés
et ça vous savez gagne un peu votre vie
oui je leur ai même dédié une chanson un
hommage sans doute un peu tardif comme
c'est toujours le cas comme
les heures bleues pour pour les
remercier justement c'est bons moments
alors drame votre père a un accident du
travail invalida 60%, il peut plus
travailler au fond dans la mine et là
vous allez habiter à Jemappes justement
voilà et alors en 1950 c'est une
première maladie vous avez pas de chance
avec la santé vous hein je m'en suis
sorti jusqu'à
présentage coronarien là c'est la
méningite excuse-moi ça me fait rire
mais l'accumulation de malheur à un
moment c'est comme le cinéma comique
l'accumulation de malheur à un moment
c'est drôle
méningite doubler une mastoïdite moelle
épinière bloquée non mais attendez c'est
pas de rigolade quoi non mais bon
aujourd'hui on en rit mais ouais
ce que j'ai pas fait pour être connu
vraiment
ça vous permet quand même de rencontrer
sur Marie Gabriel qui vous a beaucoup
apporté que vous êtes surtout appris à
lire à écrire
à l'hôpital de Louvain
c'est un autre avant voilà et puis des
séquelles un peu moins utile que lire et
écrire surdité de l'oreille droite c'est
toujours sur l'oreille droite oui
à 40% disons
pour acheter des 78 tours et venez votre
premier prix de la chanson vous gagnez 2
kg de chocolat absolument en chantant
une chanson de Luis Mariano c'était quoi
l'amour est un bouquet de violette
c'est ça
ce soir que l'on cueillance fleurette
vous faites bien Mariano
voilà vous commencez comme ça donc sur
la place du marché de Jemappes et puis
vous gagnez 2 kg de chocolat et après
votre carrière est lancé
après vous faites les balles les
kermesse les restos dans la région de
voilà dans la région de Jemappes et vous
participez on parlez de l'homme des vœux
parti seul tout à l'heure vous
participez à un radio crochet la
caravane RTL mon savon avec une chanson
que vous aviez Xavier écrite Didier si
Josette parler première chanson d'Adamo
[Musique]
16 ans
si José te confier
mes rêves d'adolescent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
votre père vous en a voulu vous allez
qu'il n'aimez pas votre nouvelle voix
surtout le curé de la paroisse qui m'a
envoyé de la chorale non mais c'est vrai
en fait votre père était pas content que
que votre voix est muet un moment et
grâce à Aznavour vous avez pu continuer
parce que lui c'était vraiment ouvert la
voie sans mauvais jeu de mots vous
souvenez cette nuit blanche que vous
avez passé à la gare du Nord vous venez
toucher un chèque de 5000 francs remis
par Aznavour d'ailleurs et les banques
étaient fermées c'est le week-end il
faisait passer toute la nuit avec votre
père salle d'attente de la gare du Nord
footballeur en même temps qu'il y avait
des hôtels ça faisait partie d'un autre
monde donc c'était normal qu'on dorme à
la salle d'attente alors on a beaucoup
d'essai discographiques à partir de là
ça a mis du temps avant d'y arriver
beaucoup de beaucoup beaucoup d'échecs
aidé par le disquaire de Jemappes
monsieur donfu hein 1965 vous êtes en
tête de tout de tous les hits parades
vous gagnez aucune je suis je vais pas
jouer les rabat-joie
donc avec vos premiers caché vous
achetez une maison à vos parents et vous
vous achetez une Alfa Romeo blanche
de disques dans le monde et quand vous
faisiez des tournées c'était vous
remplissiez plus les salles que montant
piafoot Johnny
[Applaudissements]
en 66
en 66 j'ai 4e vente de disque derrière
les Beatles
vous les rencontrez pas le McCartney
vous allez à beraude et en arrivant vous
entendez la Marseillaise vous dites
c'est pour moi
c'est pas tout à fait comme ça c'est
Charlie Maroni qui m'a dit tiens si tu
veux venir dire bonjour Beatles je parle
à George Martin c'est maintenant et au
moment où j'entre dans leur studio
j'entends la Marseillaise et Shirley
c'est Charlie ils sont gentils ils
croient que tu es français ils te jouent
la Marseillaise et pendant six mois je
l'ai cru et c'était l'intro de
absolument
[Rires]
bien et puis après alors il y a pas mal
de pas mal de galères de nouveau hein
vous pulvérisez l'Alfa Romeo dans un
accident votre père non mais c'est vrai
votre père décède dans la maison que
vous avez lui avez acheté à côté de
ragousse sur une plage
ça fait beaucoup et vous l'aimiez
beaucoup parce que quand vous avez votre
premier livre vous avez vendu 37 et
votre père vous a quand même encouragé
parce que prendre cette dix faut dire
c'est pas beaucoup
et vous dites si vous n'avez pas poussé
à continuer à cette époque là j'aurais
abandonné quoi oui moi je après avoir
gagné le crochet le concours de chant en
question bon ben la petite notoriété que
j'avais acquise c'étaitompait en
quelques mois et puis j'ai fait un
disque de disque 3 10 4 10 et ça ne
fonctionnait pas et moi je voulais
retourner aux études et c'est là que mon
père m'a vraiment surpris puisque c'est
lui qui me dit non maintenant je sais
qu'elle est ta voix elle est allée
frapper au port jusqu'à ce qu'il trouve
la bonne
alors après vous avez un petit une
petite traversée du désert aussi il faut
bien le dire un peu le creux de la vague
c'est dû à quoi votre avis mais est-ce
que c'est du chanson à la qualité des
mélodies tout simplement sans doute
entre les deux il y a eu mai 68 je dois
dire bon l'optique d'un certain public
avait bien changé et ils ont peut-être
considéré que moi j'étais pas capable
d'évoluer dans le même sens que or si
vous voulez je l'avais fait mais ils ont
peut-être pas pris la peine ou les
médias n'ont pas pris la peine de jouer
les chansons plus adéquates à l'époque
ils s'en tenait à mon image et sur
chaque disque que je sortais alors que
j'essayais de surprendre on allait
repêcher celle qui correspondait le plus
à mon image donc petit à petit et puis
il y a eu d'autres chanteurs qui sont
venus les gens se sont tournés vers
d'autres ce qui est normal et moi dans
notre coté j'avais l'occasion de chanter
ailleurs donc je n'ai pas perçu le
danger je me suis peut-être un peu trop
éloigné à un moment donné
la seule chose qui vous regrettez un peu
c'était de pas vous être bien occupé de
vos enfants non c'est une des choses en
effet que je regrette c'est que sans
doute à certains moments mes enfants ont
dû avoir besoin de moi et moi j'étais
pas là et quand je rentrais avec des
cadeaux c'était je me voyais pas les
enguirlandais donc lâchement j'ai
délégué sur les épaules de ma femme elle
a très bien fait ça ouais abusé un petit
peu de votre statut de papa héros oui
sans doute maintenant mes enfants sont
grands on a eu des discussions donc je
pense qu'ils sont convaincus que ça ne
pouvait pas être autrement que leur père
est un certain banquier on ne peut pas
le changer excusez-moi je pars de moi la
troisième personne c'était juste une
parenthèse
attention vous allez avoir vous savez
quoi
vous allez avoir une interview cauchemar
en la bouche pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien interview
quelle pourrait être pour vous Salvator
Adamo le pire des accidents conjugaux
vous faire surprendre par votre femme
quand vous êtes avec votre maîtresse
surprendre votre femme avec votre
meilleur ami ou troisième solution
surprendre
votre femme et votre maîtresse ensemble
oui je pense que ce serait surprendre ma
femme dans les bras de meilleure amie
oui pour vous ça serait le pire je pense
quel est le pire cadeau qu'on puisse
vous faire une perceuse sans fil un
abonnement dans un club de gym où le
nouveau CD dans la Rio par exemple
une perceuse sans fil
la pire situation au quotidien pour vous
c'est d'avoir une cigarette mais pas de
feu d'avoir une carte bleue mais pas de
code ou d'avoir une fille canon mais pas
de préservatif
ma femme que tout ça a été horrible
n'est-ce pas c'est ce que vous dites en
rentrant elle aussi
théorique
et alors une perceuse sans fil
pour vous la pire des illusions
apprendre qu'il y a quelqu'un dans
Casimir
dans son collant
que Goldorak est doublé pour les
cascades ou Chirac et mêlée à la faire
des HLM de la ville de Paris je pense
que comme je crois encore au Père Noël
apprendre d'un coup qu'il y a quelqu'un
dans quasimir ça bouleverserait ma vie
ça serait bien commencer
[Applaudissements]
qui sonne jamais ouais
bien sûr le pire c'est de grandir seul
de vivre seul ou de vieillir seul
je pense que c'est vieillir seul avoir
connu la compagnie et puis se retrouver
seul parce que si on grandit seul on a
le temps de s'y habituer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci Salvatore
Laurent je vais vous saluer oui c'est
très déçu parce que tu passes pour un
mec qui sait tout et il te manque une
fiche sur Salvatore
particularité anatomique que tu sembles
ignorer il a trois saints
et quand on insiste
il le montre quand on
[Applaudissements]
nichons
je le savais mais moi je suis quelqu'un
de discret vous avez vu quelqu'un de
j'ai rien à voir avec ce type là et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu